ninety percent of our American Kids
are now under critical race Theory they
used to be over it then they were
alongside it and now they are crushed
beneath its weight that means is if a
little girl goes into kindergarten if
she's white you're telling her she's bad
if she's brown or black you're telling
her she's never going to be good enough
and she's always going to be a victim
I missed that kindergarten class I would
like to speak to the kindergarten
teacher that is teaching that
and that's wrong the idea that we are
it's also not happening abiding our
children based on race based on religion
based on all of these things that's not
what was supposed to happen you have we
talked about the yeah I would love for
someone to ask Nikki Haley to Define
critical race Theory and also maybe to
Define wokeness what she says is
happening in kindergarten is not
happening period it's just not happening